we age continuing on beginner disease so
third show these shoulder-width in your
hand grip don't you don't want have to
and you don't want your hand calculating
to the site you're gonna hide behind the
first two thirds of the weapon so in
order to adapt it to your body
it's shoulder-width down don't come here
way too narrow and then you go wider out
from your shoulder you're violating that
aforementioned rule down from your
shoulders so the first thing in turn
estate is as you go here you did that
you see what I did I went to have Joe
unconsciously or I do that and as he
goes you're going to have Joe here you
see that it's back why are you so don't
move your hands around in terms of third
Joe you're here it stays there that are
joke second mistake
don't touch your head with it it's
awfully okay third mistake you're
complete the rolling of the Joe but you
didn't talk your Center so my Center has
to move around you see how it's already
dropping bow and now it continues to
drop pull fourth mistake you did stretch
you're wearing your heels on your feet
and you're not flexible and as you come
around in here your knees start to go in
like this this is not a structural
marshalese martial stance you see that
keep your knees and follow the same
rules they go out over your feet do you
understand so you gotta keep your arches
up next mistake once I get to that ain't
next bowline Mitch here starts to go
down and one
it's terminal I like much to pay more
attention to what the right hand is
doing this hand is gonna go blonde and
once he gets underneath my Center
boom I complete the drop do you
understand I'm not gonna have it go and
my Center is going you see I'm not
pulling the weapon down right or I'm all
the way down and then the hand drops
it's gonna be a point where it's there
and I'm not all the way down
Moo and I'm gonna drop it down here oh
geez yeah I'm moving but I'm not all the
way down it gets to here then finish the
movement here boom drop cap
boom here under my Center drop down i'm
the joshi and parallel so i'm going to
give you a drill you're going to
simulate the hit on the tuba so move
your weapon out of the way lighter okay
and i'm going to come and smack by joe
so it gets flat on the ground
so i'm going to be out of range
look i'm not be hit out of range and i
do the drill this would be first details
when i do the drill the weapon should
aim at him
but descended on the side of the jug
ascending you see that that is a
marriage of gravity but we don't have
your weight over the weapon so what goes
down you're now on the side so if he
comes over and he lifts the Joe bottom
you can see that don't have my weight
over it
whereas when I go here my weight is over
it see that so I have to try to not just
drop my back and I'm going to be over
that one
okay when I take the I'm over the weapon
do you see not on the side of the okay
because my goal is to check his not only
to disarm him injured him but more
importantly to check his mobility you
see that so the strike has to to push
into a center it's when I push into a
center oh I can do this key so I'm here
[Music]
the opening I need for this ski it's not
quick little moves okay
so I need all my mouse move on that
Center so that he gets delayed for me to
close together
okay let's go okay next common mistake
your hands go down together
see this you don't want that the Joe has
a whipping just like all of you all of
your art has this you don't you don't go
like that there's always a a softening
and they're releasing in a wave-like
fashion and the same goes with the Joe
say you're not going here here here here
here here look if I leave my hands here
you know that the Joe is supposed to be
at a 45 degree angle in the block but if
I bring them up together how will that
ever happen you see that so clearly when
you brought it up the right hand is
doing something slightly different and
in a different timing than the left hand
then the same thing goes when I go down
don't go from here and move them down
now you won't have the movement whoa the
right hand is moving do you see the left
hand starts afterwards so they move
differently and they move at a different
rate so we're going to go back to the
drill embryonic whoa don't move these
the same find this straight angle then
put that weight now into that give me
some lightness so I had to make up the
lines infinite night it's the same rule
right if I move you it's gonna hurt you
move you
we're going slow so there's no inertia
attention right hand in his movie at a
different rate in a different pattern
now this you watch my seat right here
draw step oh come on this is where you
make contact sure
don't hit here there's nothing there
there's no power push it it's outside
what my face is doing which one the one
see so I'm here Oh
be careful because after a while
everyone starts making contact there and
the other violation is you may contact
there you didn't really penetrate the
target so as we go to the ski now the
draw
okay let's go
so the human body due to its material a
cup skin muscle balm right fluid and
also the gravity force that's pulling on
him down and trying to keep him in place
as an object that will remain in that
state until a greater object displaces
those two things create resistance to my
weapon but when I hit it that resistance
can overcome what I'm trying to do so if
I'm over here and I hit it here
maybe my grip slips you see maybe it
knocks it out of my hands
so we're gonna just offer resistance
hold the end do you understand these
representing that resistance okay so
we're going to do a couple of things I
want you to slide your hands back like
that so you sliding it through this here
resistance okay and I'm gonna let him go
with me knees up I wanted you to slide
one hand like that you see how I did
that it's like cool you see that
okay now resistance just just wait maybe
you try it first show me the movement
slide it through your front hand
there you go more like cool there you go
here we go
does it work
is he sliding it anymore no no he's not
you got to try to slide it slide it
through it's not working okay now let's
try it under your armpit and you hit you
hit here go
go so much displacement No
okay so let's just look if he had let's
put my front surface with this line okay
and he goes to displace it go so even if
you could do it how much displacement
could there actually be because the how
much penetration if you have with no
resistance passed the line you see so he
goes you see not not not fast because
the resistance is slowing down the
percussion and then not T he goes it's
not deep he hold on right and I do I
think if you were shuffling you would go
like that I don't think any of you would
go I don't think any of you would go you
put your weight into it puh so I'm gonna
add my movement down with that Joe
breaking the backlight to hand out
this is drill to first drill and once
you try those other two things
drill to get there Joe
engage the back leg Brown pop back foot
boost outcomes of jump drill 3 don't run
you do drill - oh and then drive it up
throw 3
okay let's go okay so back to the
embryonic form but I want to see that
because I've seen this stuff you see
this crap and then this counting cute
so we clean up all this day
there's a rock there okay my movement is
quick my strategy is to get inside and
the weapon it's a very common strategy
don't want to fight out there
his China Jesus keep me out there that's
why he's hitting the hounds first you
see can hit the hands at the same rate
and I hit his head
so my movement is very fluid I do my
movement as I come in hey but I'm loose
I'm not stick he goes up I had my eye on
a cart but I'm loose you should be able
to feel this I can you know that I'm
already absorbing boom he goes same
thing that's too late go back I should
feel his movement you see
[Applause]
[Music]
what your my Kelly's gonna do you see
go back - he goes see hitting my head
because what watch work
watch your knife dirty as I feel that I
yield to it so I'm on the other side
then I make sure my heist notch at my
high will be checked if I move you into
the side and stay here it's pulling
weight on my front foot so I stay with
it you goes to scheme you can
[Music]